Musik Jede neue Woche, wir hören ihnen zu, jede neue Woche, sie geben keine Ruh ein Kapitän ein Bahnfahrer die Storys sind der Hit
der Podcast Ufo Podcast ist immer noch der Woche. Nico kommt, ist ihm direkt von den Seiten ins Mikrofon gehüpft und wir haben das gehört. Vielen Dank. Ganz unabhängig von dem Intro ist mir eingefallen, dass es in unserer Band damals immer eine riesengroße Diskussion war, wer wie laut ist. Und der Gitarrist wollte immer so laut sein. Und jetzt rückblickend klingt das so albern, als ob man da so einen Metastreit eigentlich mit so einem Lächeln im Gesicht geführt hat. Nee, aber es war unser voller Ernst, dass ich dann immer nachher noch, nach dem Soundcheck, zu dem Mischer gegangen bin und habe gesagt, ich wurde von allen Seiten bestochen, jetzt sind 20 Euro, mach mich noch mal ein bisschen lauter. Und der ist da als reicher Mann rausgegangen, als gemachter Mensch. Und ich habe gesagt, kann ich noch, weil Gesang und so geht ja oft immer dann unter und so. Und es ist auch so ein weirdes, ja, ich erkläre dem gerade meinen Designjob, weil er hat ja nicht ohne Grund mich so laut gemacht, wie ich zu sein habe. Und dann würde er so so komischen Tricks, die man angewendet hat, im Soundcheck ein bisschen leiser zu singen. Oh, das ist schon next level. Oder so das Mikrofon ganz weit weghalten vom Mund. Und dann jeder Bassist, mit dem ich gesprochen habe, jede Bassistin, hat immer noch ein bisschen Power zurückgehalten. Um dann, wenn er auf die Bühne gegangen wird ... Dampen Bassisten!
Und ich wette aber, das wissen auch alle TontechnikerInnen,
wissen das dann auch, dass sie einfach dann
den Bassisten auf die Bühne sehen,
mit so einem wissenden Lächeln im Gesicht,
sehen, dass er nochmal in die Röhre auftritt
und dann direkt so ein Schalter
sich dann ein bisschen was zurückgehalten hat,
um noch ein bisschen zurückzugehen.
Bei mir war es immer andersrum, ich wollte immer leiser sein.
Ich habe gesagt, mach mich ruhig leise, mach mich ruhig leise,
muss man nicht hören. Ich weiß nur,
weil er hat hier gerade fantastisch Gitarre gespielt
und zurückgehalten hat, um noch ein bisschen zurückzugehen. Bei mir war es immer andersrum, ich wollte immer leiser sein, ich habe gesagt, mach mich ruhig leise, mach mich ruhig leise, muss man nicht hören. Ich weiß nur, weil er hat hier gerade fantastisch Gitarre gespielt und ich erinnere mich noch, wir haben, ich war ja auch im langen Gitarrenunterricht und dann irgendwann kam mal, ich glaube, den kennt man nur in Gitarrenkreisen, weil ich habe ja klassische Konzertgitarre gespielt, also natürlich... Ja, eine sehr kleine Bubble, aber eine sehr spezifische Bubble. In die man aber leicht und ungewollt reinrutscht, weil alle wollen Gitarre spielen, um mit Wonderwall den Schwarm aus der Klasse zu bezürzen. Und dann spielt man halt zehn Jahre lang Francisco Caroli und Fernando Targa. Ja, die Gavotte, die Gavotte in G-Dur. Spanischen Komponisten aus dem 17. Jahrhundert und denkt sich, wann kommt Stay Away to Heaven? Ich habe jetzt Andantino zweimal gespielt, aber wo ist Stay Away to Heaven? Und dann kam Michael Langer, einer der Choryphäen der klassischen Gitarre für Zehnjährige und Kleine. Du meinst der Van Halen der klassischen Konzertgitarre. Ja, ja. Der Eddie Van Halen. Der Jimi Hendrix des Ich zupfe meine Saiten, des Streiche sie nicht. Ich habe lange Fingernägel an vier Fingern meiner rechten Hand, dann spiele ich Gitarre. Und diese Fussbank, die man vergisst, diese sehr hoch eingestellte Fussbank, die speziell für diese kleine Bubble entwickelt wurde. Genau, die Fussbank für den linken Fuß, damit das linke Knie oben ist, damit man die Gitarre da drauf positionieren kann. Niemand will in dieser Bubble sein. Diese Fussbank will nicht in dieser Bubble sein. Vor allem, wenn du Gitarre spielst und du bist der krasse Typ in der Klasse, die Gitarre spielt und dann ist halt auch Vanessa auf der Party und du hast halt zufällig da die Gitarre bei, weil du gerade vom Gitarrenunterricht kommst um 23 Uhr. Und dann sagt jemand, ey, du spielst doch Gitarre und dann holst du die Gitarre raus. Das ist schon awkward, die Gitarre hinzubringen. Aber stell dir mal vor, wie es ist, wenn du noch einen Fschemel mit auspacken musst. Du musst deinen Fußschemel noch auspacken, deine Noten, also so einen kleinen Notenständer, den auszupacken an eine Stunde. Das Stimmgerät, die Stimmgabel. Klar, aber jeder kennt ja diesen Notenständer. Und es gibt zwei Arten von Menschen, die ihn aufbauen können und die ihn nicht aufbauen können. Ich gehörte zu ersterer Fraktion, die ihn aufbauen konnte, aber dafür 20 Minuten brauchte, wie jeder andere auch. Und vor allem dann sieht man die Person auch nicht, die man bezirzen will, weil du hast ein riesiges Heft davor, wo irgendwie noch so alberne Kinderfiguren drauf sind auf dem Heft. Also es wird, ich glaube, die Herzrate der Dame steigt stark, wenn sie die Gitarre sieht. Bei Fussschemel und Notenständer sinkt das allerdings wieder unter Nullgrad. Ich glaube, es hört schon auf bei ihr, wenn sie diesen dicken Hals, dieser dicken Konzertgitarre sieht, dieser pummelige Hals, dieser Stirnacken mit den Nylonseiten. Und es ist nicht so eine beklebte Fender-Stahlseitengitarre. Ich glaube, da hört es bei Vanessa schon auf. Da hat sie sich schon umgedreht und guckt lieber den Jungs mal Fussballspielen zu. Und dann haben wir das Konzert von Michael Langer gesehen, dem krassesten der krassen, und war natürlich verzaubert, hingerissen. Wir hatten, wo wurden Teil des Effekts, den wir seit Jahren versucht haben herzustellen und zu beschwören. Und der hatte eine krasse Technik drauf, weil der hat nämlich am Ende von jedem Lied noch die Gitarre so genommen und so wie so geschwungen vielleicht, als würde man so ein Kind hin und her wiegen, um so die Klangwellen noch zu unterstützen. Weil du kannst ja bei der Gitarre auch die Seiten, wenn du zum Beispiel den Gitarrenschaft nach hinten ziehst, also das Holz ziehst, kannst du alle Seiten nochmal anders spannen. Unmerklich anders klingen lassen. Ja, und das war dieser Effekt, und er spielt und am Ende hat er dann noch so diese schwingende Bewegung gemacht. Und danach hat jeder von uns bei jedem noch so stümperhaft dumm hingezumpften Scheissstück am Ende nach Ah nee, tschuldigung, bring, nee, bring, und dann am Ende noch so diese Gitarre schwingen lassen. Unnötig, weil der eine Scheiss-Fettfinger eh die Seiten die ganze Zeit abgeblockt haben. Aber das war für mich so der Punkt, wo ich dachte, ja, da ist einfach Style over Substance, da hat Michael Langer meine Musikkarriere ruiniert. Michael Langer, was macht er heute? Ich weiß es nicht, ich hoffe, der macht immer noch tolle Arrangements von bekannten Stücken für die klassische Konzertgitarre. Shoutout an Herrn Langer da draussen. Ich habe mich aber jetzt bei dem Gedanken erwischt, namentlich nach dem Film Coco, dass ich dachte, davon wollte ich immer weg. Ich war ja wie du. Das abschreckendes Beispiel. Ja, weil ich war ja immer wie du. Ich wollte ja auch Wonderwall spielen. Ich wollte die Akkorde, die Four Chords, mit denen man überleben kann. Genau. Da draußen an den Lagerfeuern. Du willst das Lagerfeuer begleiten können, du willst ja auch mitsingen. Das soll ja nicht so anspruchsvoll sein, dass du dich nicht mehr auf Singen konzentrieren kannst. Ich will mitsingen, ich brauche vier Akkorde, man brauche ich gar nicht, dann bin ich hier raus. Das ist der Plan eines jeden jungen Gitarristen. Man geht rein und lernt dann wirklich Andantino von Adagio Frederico in Gesus 4. So, das kann man dann irgendwann und denkt sich dann so coole Herausforderungen, okay,
man bleibt dann da ein bisschen drin, kommt nicht
wieder raus, weil es ist ja auch wahnsinnig unangenehm,
so ein Gitarrenlehrer, für den das ja irgendwie alles
ist, dass der Dichter, also für mich war immer das Gefühl,
ich bin seine Welt so ein bisschen
und ich kann jetzt unmöglich, jetzt will ich Schluss machen,
ich kann ihm jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt kein Gitarrenlehrer
mehr nehme oder ich kann ihm auch nicht, weil
er hat diese grossen, feuchten Augen, wenn er über diese Songs spricht, ich kann ihm jetzt nicht sagen, dass ich jetzt kein Gitarrenunterricht mehr nehme. Oder ich kann ihm auch nicht, weil er hat diese grossen, feuchten Augen, wenn er über diese Songs spricht.
Ich kann ihm jetzt nicht sagen, können wir mit der Wonderwall des Komponisten Oasis machen.
Er hätte jetzt auch nicht so Lust drauf gehabt.
Also lässt man es einfach still bei sich gehen.
Wie viele Sachen in dem Alter, lässt man es einfach passieren.
Ja.
So, und das ist ein Problem.
Und irgendwann wird man dann gezwungen, fantastisch spanische Gitarre spielen zu können. Genau. Also das ist nicht das schlimmste Outcome. Damals weiß man es aber nicht zu schätzen, weil du kommst nicht in so eine Situation, wo du dich mal auf Spaß irgendwie mit einem Sombrero und einem Poncho irgendwo hinsetzt und fantastisch spanische Gitarre spielst. Denn deine Aufschrittsmöglichkeiten sind Fussschemel, Riesennotending und die langen Fingernägel auch. Also ab einem gewissen Punkt spielst du mit langen Fingernägel. Das habe ich nie gemacht, weil ich bin nicht bescheuert. Und ich kann mich noch erinnern, dass wir im Schullandheim waren und ein Schwarm, in die so die halbe Klasse verliebt war, haben dann auch so einen anderen Gitarrenspieler gefragt, warum hast du eigentlich immer so lange Fingernägel? Und er so, ja damit spiele ich Gitarre und sie so, r rr. Aber ich dachte mir nur so, wow, acht Jahre meines Lebens beziehungsweise enden in rr. Also, Guitars died. Das ist der Moment, wo Gitarren keine Rolle mehr gespielt haben. Aber da fängt es an einen Brunftzirkus. Aber ich glaube, das ist der Moment, wo du anfängst, der wirkliche Künstler zu werden, weil der coole Jog, der Wonderwall in einer halben Stunde gelernt hat, um alle Frauenfach zu legen, der wird ja kein echter, ernster Musiker. Um Künstler und Musiker zu werden, musst du ja gebrochen sein, du musst ja gebrochen werden, du musst ja der sehnende, der enttäuschte Künstler sein, der dann still zu Hause sitzt und halt phantastisch spielt, aber niemand hört ihn. Da willst du ja eigentlich hin, das ist ja der Langzeiterfolg. Ja, oder kauf dich im Plektrum. Und dann habe ich auch gehört, irgendwann das zu spielen und fantastisch spanische Gitarre spielen zu können. Und habe vor einem Jahr den Film Coco gesehen. Und das fand ich so toll, halt diese ganzen spanischen Songs, die ich auch immer spielen konnte, da zu hören, eben fantastisch gespielt, mit diesem kleinen kleinen Jungen mit dem großen Sombrero auf, der durch die spanischen Theodades läuft und spielt. Und da dachte ich mir, das hätte ich sein können, aber nein, ihr vergesst ja die Fussschemel scheiße. Das stimmt, da haben die Animatoren sich bewusst dazu entschlossen, die Fussschemel rauszuretuschieren, was ich finde eine Sünde ist, aber rückblickend bin ich natürlich froh, dass ich es so gelernt habe, weil es natürlich viel ergiebiger und letzten Endes auch cooler ist, als wenn ich jetzt Stairway to Heaven spielen könnte, was mich so interessiert. Du kannst jetzt Stairway to Heaven spielen, ich kann jetzt nicht mehr Digga-Watt spielen. Dann lass es doch zusammentun und wir machen wirklich ein Abenderlebnis für die ganze Gitarrenfamilie, wo alle Spaß haben können, wo Eltern ihre Kinder hinbringen können, um dann zu entscheiden, dann kann man sich so choose your character entscheiden, willst du lieber den Stefan-Weg oder den Florentin-Weg gehen, willst du lieber mit Stefan in die Kinderbetten von den jungen Damen aus deiner Klasse oder willst du mit Florentin allein sein? Kann man das Kind auch wieder zurücknehmen, wenn die ganze Veranstaltung zu creepy ist? Nee, du verlierst dann halt alle Erfahrungspunkte auf dem Weg, die du schon gemacht hast. Aber du kannst dann schon einen anderen Weg gehen. Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube, alle Eltern und ich als Elternteil mal irgendwann eingeschlossen, glaube ich, werden immer den langweiligen Florentin-Weg nehmen. Der ungefährliche Fußschemelweg. Ja, aber ist das eine Art der Eltern, die sagen, ich will nicht, dass mein neunjähriger Sohn Sex hat. Ich schicke den zu dem Lehrer, der schön noch mal für den Karolik hatte. Ich schreibe ihm das aus. Das stimmt schon. Vielleicht ist es ähnlich, dass die Eltern sagen, komm, warte mal noch mal mit Wonderwall, bis der irgendwie 16 ist und jetzt erst mal schön Adagio. Wonderwall spielen können, ist letztlich wie ein Tattoo. Ja, das stimmt. Du kommst dann in einen Kreis rein, in so einen Erwachsenenkreis und verlierst dein Kind ein Stück weit. Es ist eine Macht, die zu junge Menschen nicht haben dürfen. Das stimmt schon, das ist verboten. Wohingegen Gavotte mit langen Fingernägeln so ein bisschen so ist, wie so ein großes Kondom überstürmen, wo ja auch nichts passieren mal. Ja, genau, das stimmt schon. Der Fußschemel kümmert sich um alles, was deine Zahnspange oder deine zu grossen Hosen nicht eh schon regelt. Die hätte ich auch. Irgendwann war ich an einem Punkt, und das war der Tiefpunkt Rock Bottom war für mich ein bisschen eine Zeit, wo ich auch mit Fußschemel Gitarre gespielt habe und grossen Notenständer vor einem. So eine Topffrisur, dann weil ich so extreme riesige Überbiss hatte mit so riesigen Hauern vorne, die schon so groß sind wie meine Zähne. Jetzt war es jetzt proportional zu meiner Kabelgröße. Mit dem du aber cool Gitarre spielen konntest wiederum, das war natürlich das Highlight. Deswegen brauchte ich die Fingernägel nicht, deswegen konnte ich mit meinen langen Zähnen spielen. Hatte eine Zahnspange mit diesem Bügel hinten. Nein, die gibt es nicht wirklich. Und war mit der Gitarre, der Zahnspange mit Bügel hinten und diesem Topfschnitt mit den Messdienern in so einem Off-Brand-Freizeitpark, was vorher mal das Kernwasser Wunderland, was vorher mal ein Atomkraftwerk war. Das war
Kernwasser Wunderland.
Mit dem Maskottchen Kerni.
Komischerweise wurden deine Zähne immer länger,
je mehr Zeit du in dem Wasser verbracht hast.
Da war ich wieder Messdiener.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht, dass es dieses
Bügelzahnspangen wirklich gibt. Ich dachte,
es ist nur so ein Comic-Vehikel,
um den noch schrecklicher aussehen zu lassen.
Ich habe so alle Klischees, die es gibt, die man so kennt. so von Spongebob oder irgendwelchen anderen Nickelodeon-Shows von den Nerds oder den uncoolen Leuten, alle habe ich so einverleibt. Nichts habe ich ausgelassen. Ich war auch bei den Fahrtfiltern, so diese ganze Theater-AG, Musical gesungen, alles das, wo man draufhauen kann, habe ich mal irgendwann verkörpert für einen kurzen Zeitpunkt. Und dann bin ich da mit diesen ganzen Loser-Sachen ins Kernwasser Wunderland gekommen und bin rausgekommen als normaler Mensch. Du hättest dann ein sehr uncooler Superheld werden können, du hättest Nerdman werden können, als du da irgendwie in das alte Reaktorwasser da reingefallen bist und dann hat sich alles so zusammengeschweißt und dann wird diese Brille dir angeschweißt und diese übergestülpten Haare und alles ist für immer. Aber am Ende unbesiegbar. Am Ende unbesiegbar, ja. Nichts kommt an dich ran, weil du dein Herz nicht öffnen kannst für andere Leute. Nichts kommt an mich ran. Auch keine Frau kommt jemals an mich ran. Du bist der Konter gegen Wonder Woman einfach. Kann dir nicht wehtun. Niemand kann Wonder Woman Besuch besiegen, aber ich als Nerdman. Well, well, well, das war Rock Bottom. Das war Rock Bottom. Vielen Dank nochmal an Nico für das Intro auf seiner fantastischen Gitarre. Ich hoffe, dir geht es besser. Einen anderen Weg, den du einschlagen wirst, oder je nachdem, wie du das machst, dass du das Beste rausholst. Und Kunst basiert auf Enttäuschung, Trauer und Schmerz, von daher auch nicht schlecht, davon was zu sammeln. Ich habe, apropos Schmerz, wie du merkst, mir meinen Bart komplett abrasiert. Ja, ich sehe dich leider immer nur hinter dem Mikrofon. Ich kann gar nicht... Ach so! Weil es ist einfach dieser Rasierer und es nervt mich tierisch, weil ich war, ich wollte ausgehen abends, ging wieder aus irgendwelchen Gründen, sondern musste man, wollte mich noch fertig machen, frisch, schön meine Gesichtsbehaarung in schöne Bahnen lenken und dabei plötzlich habe ich meine elektrischen Rasierer angemacht, stell die richtige Klingenlänge ein, leider hat sich aber die Klingenlänge oben nicht verschoben, was ich eben nicht gemerkt habe, und mache einmal quasi durchs Gesicht und merke, oh scheiße, da habe ich mich so aufgeregt, wie ich mich seit langer Zeit nicht mehr aufgeregt habe und habe dann alles abrasiert und jetzt sehe ich wieder aus wie zwölf, was man nicht wissen will. Du willst, das ist ein unangenehmes Gefühl, bevor man ausgeht und ja eigentlich dann in so einer hochgepeitschten mir geht es total gut, ich habe eine gute Zeitstimmung sein müsste. Ging nicht. Vielleicht ist es gar nicht aber nötig, dann den kompletten Bart abzunehmen. Ich habe manchmal das Gefühl, bei vielen Bartfrisuren war die Grundlage, ich säbe mir einmal die Seite weg, merke, oh fuck, ich habe alles weggesäbelt, mach es auf der anderen Seite auch noch. So diese klassische Guti. Einfach Symmetrie herstellen und du bist gut. Symmetrie rett ich versucht. Du musst dann auf der anderen Seite noch einen Streifen raus und dann kannst du einfach sagen, nein, weil Symmetrie kann ja kein Unfall sein und die Leute denken dann, okay, gut, du hast ein bisschen weirde Bartfrisur, aber das ist gewollt. Tatsächlich, wo du es gerade gesagt hast, habe ich es genau auch so versucht, weil wenn du das Problem feststellst, hast du ja noch, du bist ja noch nicht bereit aufzugeben. Nein. Du machst ja nicht sofort alles weg. Nee, kämpfst weiter. Erstmal, ja genau, erst mal zehn Minuten Wut auch auf den Rasierer, wie das denn sein kann überhaupt. Schreien, Schmerz, Wut. Ruft Braun, Braun, Braun, dass alle sich fragen müssen. Sein Nachbar klopft und sagt, was denn? Ich sag, Braun, ich mein nicht sie. Was ich gemacht habe, ist, ich habe die obere Hälfte der einen Seite des Oberlippenbartes abgemacht. Oh, okay. Weißt du? Ja, also wir haben ein Haar halben Hitler oder was? Halben Hitler, nicht richtig, weil er müsste die andere da, nee, aber die Hälfte von dieser kleinen, dieser kleinen Ufer, was man hat, diese kleine Gracht, die man von der Nase zur Lippe geht, die kennst du, ne, dieses hier, diese Falte. Die hat auch keinen Namen, glaube ich. Falls ihr der lokale Dialekt hat, bitte schickt sie uns. Die bis hin quasi Ende der Lippe habe ich abrasiert. Und dann habe ich natürlich versucht, erst mal, wie du schon sagst, unterbewusst, erst mal Symmetrie herzustellen, habe die andere Seite wegrasiert, aber das merkwürdigste, was es auch nicht gibt tatsächlich, die merkwürdigste
Gesichtsfrisur, die ich jemals hatte.
Du meinst, du hast einen Vollbart, aber ohne Schnauzer.
Aber ohne Schnauzer.
Noch nicht, das könnte als der Tietze in die
Geschichte der Bartfrisur eingehen.
Bitte nicht. Doch, macht das mal, schickt uns mal Bilder,
rasiert euch den Tietze
und geht damit auf die Strasse, einfach um
rückwirkend eine Ehre zu retten.
Alles geht als Frisur.
Wenn der Namensgeber das nur zwei Sekunden hatte und dann sagt er, albern und macht es weg, aber er bleibt Namensgeber. Es gibt ja, dann dachte ich, habe ich das auch so gegoogelt, weil es noch so viele Bartfrisuren gibt, die ich jetzt noch hinkriege. Aber alle basieren auf dem Konzept Oberlippenbart. Also der ist zuerst da und dann wächst alles drumherum. Ja, das stimmt schon, ja. Ja, aber es gibt keine Bartfrisur, wo ausgerechnet der fehlt, aber der Rest ist da. Ja, du kannst natürlich noch so einen Ralf-Zacher-Ziegenbart oder sowas in der Richtung kriegen, aber du brauchst auch recht lange Haare. Ja, die hatte ich auch nicht. Jetzt ist alles ab und ich hoffe, es wächst schnell nach. Aber dann habe ich den Rasierer verflucht, wo ich dachte, weil ich habe diese Regel, dass Dinge, die ich häufig in der Woche benutze, die können ruhig was kosten. Ich bin bereit, dafür Geld auszugeben. So für Dinge, die man sehr häufig benutzt, wie ein Laptop zum Beispiel oder gute Kopfhörer, Fernseher, Dinge, die man einfach häufig benutzt. Und Rasierer gehört ja dazu. Deswegen ist es auf meiner Liste der, dürfen ruhig was kosten Gegenstände. Aber jetzt auch in einem gesunden Rahmen, also nicht irgendwie von Louis Vuitton vergoldet oder sowas, das macht ja keinen Sinn.
In einem soliden, Stiftung Warentest hat auch abgenickt.
Ich glaube, du bist ja gar nicht so weit weg von der normalen Meinung.
Du musst dich, glaube ich, gar nicht so sehr erklären.
Nee, aber ich möchte mich erklären.
So, und dann habe ich mich entschieden für den besten Rasierer, den ich gefunden habe, und der kostet halt so 60 Euro. Ja. Und dann macht der halt sowas, denke ich mir. Ja. Dann stellt man halt da die Rasierlänge ein und das ist ein Trimmer auch, glaube ich, ist das richtige Wort. Dann macht man das weg und dann hat man diese Probleme. Warum kann es denn keinen Rasierer geben, der darauf achtet oder das nicht hat? Ja. Und ich bin nur bereit, Geld auszugeben, mehr als 60 Euro für einen guten Rasierer, den ich jeden Tag benutze, aber nein, das ist auch der aus der Werbung, wo die ganzen Bayern-Spieler dann sind und sagen, das ist ein guter Trimmer. Ja. Ja, ist schwierig, aber mich würde natürlich interessieren, wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel für einen Rasierer viel Geld ausgibst, wo du sagst, du benutze ich häufig, wofür gibst du dir dann richtig wenig Geld aus? Also was hast du wirklich zur schäbigste Qualität? So richtig schlechtes Snowboard zum Beispiel. Du hast so ein richtig, wirklich so ein 12,99 Euro Plastik-Snowboard. Ganz schlechtes Snowboard. Das benutze ich einmal im Jahr. Das ist richtig schäbig, das ist zu klein, das ist krumm. Das geht sofort kaputt auch. Das ist viel zu klein, das sind Ski. Also was ist ganz hinten auf deiner Priorität? Das ist ein Skier. Mein Snowboard ist ein gebrauchter Skier. Weil ich dachte, damit komme ich schon über die Runden. Die sind super billig, wenn du nur einen kaufst. Zu zweit kosten die teilweise 200, 300 Euro. Wenn du nur einen kaufst, kriegst du die für sechs Euro hinterher. Die spinnen, denke ich mir. Die spinnen. Ja, weil die haben teilweise einen verloren, liegt im Wald und wollen den anderen loswerden. Klar. Du kannst teilweise auch einzelne Schuhe super billig kaufen. Meine Stöcke sind so Nordic Walking Stöcke. Alternativ einfach so aus dem Baumarkt, so eine Stange. Und du hast auch keine Schuhe, sondern du stehst mit Socken auf dem einen Ski und versuchst dich irgendwie über Schnee zu heissen. Aber mit mehreren Socken, übereinander. Das muss schon sein, aber sehr billige Socken. Nein, da hast du mir nicht zugehört, weil Socken benutzt sich ja jeden Tag. Socken bitte zu jeden Tag. Und deswegen kostet es richtig viel Geld. Richtig viel Geld. Und du kannst aber richtig teuer, aber sehr dünn, so dass du selber skalieren kannst, wie dick die Socken sind. Und bei kalten Tagen kannst du einfach vier Paare tragen und dann im Schnee einfach zwanzig Paare. Was ich so richtig schlecht habe, ist zum Beispiel so Tee. Ich trinke ganz selten im Jahr Tee, da habe ich so den billigsten Billow-Tee.
So billig, so aus dem Müll vom Nachbarn genommen, dritter, vierter Aufguss, so wirklich dann ganz schlechter Tee. Da muss man richtig lange ziehen lassen, um überhaupt irgendwie Geschmack rauszupressen. Also so einen Monat ziehen. So jetzt komm, voran, Mensch! Und nee, ich brauche noch ... Nee, weil so ...
Und die Reflexion, dass guter Tee schnell ist,
finde ich auch eine interessante Weise.
Der gute Tee ist gut zwei Sekunden und der ist perfekt.
Der ist perfekt. Das erwarte ich von einem guten Tee.
Aber wie man an meinen Ausführungen merkt,
trinke ich nicht so häufig Tee.
Und denke immer nur, falls jemand was Tee braucht bei mir,
dann habe ich Tee da, aber halt sehr billig.
Dinge, die ich nicht häufig benutze, sind sehr, sehr schlecht. Aber finde ich gut, wenn ich so wirklich furchtbarer Tee so in so einer unbeschrifteten Plastiktüte, einfach irgendwo kommt das her, niemand weiß genau woher. Niemand weiß genau, wo es ist. Und sie hat so eine Woche. Da muss man so eine Woche, muss man das da reinballern. Ich habe mich letztens auch mit Tee beschäftigt, weil ich hab irgendwie Bock auf, ich mag die Idee von Kräutertee. So irgendwie, und ich glaube, was ich eigentlich meine, wenn ich sag Kräutertee, ich mag Almdudler oder Bionade oder sowas oder diesen Kräutergeschmack. Und dann denke ich mir, ja geil, da machst du dir so einen geilen Kräutertee. Ich glaube, was ich vergesse ist, dass das gut schmeckt, weil halt viel Zucker drin ist. Und ich versuche aber trotzdem Kräuter nehmen. Ich habe mir ganz verschiedene Kräuter besorgt, so ganz so Boxhorn-Klee, Marillen-Kraut, Schlieren-Stieg, Schleisinger-Klee, Krötzgras, also wirklich so die weirdesten Gräser und Kräuter, die als Tee verkauft werden, aber wahrscheinlich einfach Unkraut ist. Also da geht jemand auf dem Feld und rupft da einfach was aus, verkauft mir das als Tee. Völlig richtig. Und jetzt bin ich gerade dabei, die perfekte Kräutermischung für mich herzustellen. Und ich habe, glaube ich, jetzt so vier Kannen Kräutertee genossen und alle waren scheusslich. Ja, scheusslich. Wirklich scheusslich. Aber ich habe mir die runtergequält, weil ich die Idee eines Kräutertees so gerne mag. So aus dem Wald und ja und die Essenzen des Waldes kommen da zusammen und alles schön und gesund. Hast du irgendein System? Nein, null System. Du hast ein System mit so Schlierenkraut. Ich will, dass es wie Ricola schmeckt, aber halt ohne Zucker halt so. Und dann ist es halt immer grauenvoll. Hast du schon mal süße Kräuter gegoogelt, im Sinne von, wie du ein bisschen Süße reinbekommst? Ja, halt Zitronenmelisse, was ich auch immer noch crazy finde. Das ist halt so eine Art Fake-Zitrone. Ja, Wahnsinn, ne? Wie kann das sein? Die Natur ist da wirklich einfach so lustig gewesen. Einfach Copy-Paste-Zitrone, wir brauchen noch eine Melisse. Ja, fuck. Ja, nimm da Zitronengeschmack, das merkt kein Mensch. Aber kam das durch den Geschmack, also man hat das probiert und hat gesagt, das schmeckt genauso wie diese gelbe Frucht, die wir schon mal hatten, in leicht, in bekömmlich, in bonbonartig. Ich weiß es, ich weiß nicht, ob das... Weil ehrlich, ich finde es nicht, dass es wie Zitrone schmeckt. Es ist so gut gelehrt. Du meinst, du könntest in einem Blindtest eine Zitronenmelisse und Zitrone und Zitronenfalter auseinanderhalten. Ist das dein Ernst? Ja, ich glaube, ich könnte aber nicht diese so Zitronenbonbons aus Zitroneneis. Das schmeckt für mich eher wie Zitronenmelisse. Eis hat aber nichts mit Zitrone zu tun. Nee, so Zitroneneis. Ach so, ich dachte, du meinst diese Eisbonbons, die nach Eis schmecken. A.k.a. gefro meine Zitroneis, ja auch irre, dass man diese Bonbons, Eis, Wasserbonbons, mehr davon. Aber lustigerweise Wasserbonbons oder Gasbonbons würde man nicht essen. Würde man nicht schlecht verkaufen. Aber Eis ist das eine Aggregatzustand, wo man sagt, das kann man auch als Bonbon verkaufen. Lass uns mal die Top-3-Aggregatzzustände von Wasser kurz abklappern. Bei mir auf Platz Nummer drei definitiv Wasserdampf. Hasse ich, habe ich keinen Bock drauf, tut weh, wenn du deine Hand drüber hältst, während Wasser kochst, kondensiert überall, im Bad, beschlägt den Spiegel, Wasserdampf ist für mich raus. Ja genau, beschlagene Spiegel sind für mich auch, sind für mich nämlich auch so irgendwie synonym, ist gleich für mich alles so. Wasserdampf hat irgendwie so schlecht konnotiert. Bei dir auch auf Platz drei? Super auf Platz drei, also beid abgeschlagen auf Platz drei. Auch weil ich so denke, Wasserdampf, aha, interessant, man kann es verbrennen, bei 100 Grad irgendwann wird es dann in die Luft gestoßen, wird ein aggregatisches Stamm, Wasserdampf, jetzt ist ja doch mehr mit möglich. Kann man damit eine Dampflok antreiben? Nein. Wobei doch. Kann man damit ein Kraftwerk betreiben und Strom herstellen, der unser gesamtes Leben versorgt? Ja, gut, aber es ist ... Wait, wait a minute. Wie fühlst du denn ein Atomkraftwerk? Doch auch nur Wasser zum Kochen bringen, oder? Ja, ja. Bei mir. Bei mir ist ... Wasser jetzt um deine Turbine anzutreiben. Wasser dann ist gerade ... Ihr könnt ja nur diesen raren Moment beobachten, einmal im Monat, wo bei mir sich die Aggregatzustände ändern. Ja, Stefan holt gerade ein Notizbuch raus und streicht wild Dinge durch. Meine letzte Liste. Wasser dann ist gerade auf Platz 1 gelandet. Okay, was ist der neue Platz 3? Bei mir immer noch auf Platz 3. Eis. Ich ble Eis. Eis ist auf drei. Ist kalt, Zunge bleibt dran kleben, Eisbonbons leiden sich ja nur den Namen, der Name ist gut. Aber du als leidenschaftlicher Snowboarder müsstest das doch lieben. Ich habe keine guten Erfahrungen mit meinem Snowboard gemacht, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich habe mich sehr doll verletzt, außer meine Knöchel, wegen meiner vielen Socken. Sonst habe ich alles gebrochen und meine Snowboard-Erfahrungen waren nicht gut. Platz Nummer zwei der Aggregatszustände von Wasser ist für mich Wasser. Ganz klar, obwohl es namensgebend ist für das ganze Element, bei mir ist auch Platz zwei. Ja, schmeckt schal, ist erfrischend, aber es fehlt irgendwie so das gewisse etwas, der gewisse Kick. Im Schwimmbad hast du nur Wasser mit Chlor, wo man auch sagt, warum nicht nur Wasser, warum reicht das nicht, warum muss da Chlor dazu, da fehlt offensichtlich eine Komponent, die wichtig ist. Ansonsten Regen, oh nee, ist auch nass und so, nee, Meer, da ist auch Salz drin. Irgendwie hat die Natur schon gecheckt, dass Wasser ein bisschen lame war. Manchmal ist Salz dabei, bei Süsswasser extra noch ein bisschen Süssstoff mit drin und so. Von daher, Platz Nummer zwei, Wasser. Finde ich auch. Wasser ist nicht so praktisch, man kann nicht so schnell da drüber kommen. Es ist super langsam, ein Schiff ist super langsam. Flugzeug schießt dahin, Luft, Flug, Schiff, boah. Ja, eklig, also man ist sehr langsam selbst der schnellste Schiff der Welt nur 50 kmh schnell oder sowas. Man kann ertrinken? Man kann ertrinken, man kann ersüppeln, man kann reinfallen, sich frieren, man kann absaufen, man kann zu viel Wasser in die Lunge bekommen und dann sterben letztlich. Ganz viele Schätze liegen unter Wasser, gibt das Wasser nicht her, wo sind die? Und das grösste Minus ist, wir wissen zu wenig, über was in dem Wasser vorgeht. Deswegen auch das Eins. So ein, zwei Meter gucken, aber mehr nicht. Deswegen auch das Eins, mein persönlicher Favorite ist Wasserdampf. Wir leben vom Wasserdampf. Vergesst alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe, denn sowohl damals so die ersten Menschen, die sich schnell vorbeweg haben, mit einer Dampflok zum Beispiel, da wurde nur Dampf bewegt und hat alles möglich gemacht, hat Turbinen beschleunigt und so weiter. Wir haben jetzt Atomkraftwerke, wo wir ohne CO2-Emissionen quasi, weird, dass das jetzt die Richtung ist, die wir eingeschlagen haben, Strom erzeugt für uns. Man merkt, es ist ein neuer Platz eins bei dir, du hast dich noch nicht so richtig eingefühlt in deinen neuen Platz eins. Du musst gerade ein bisschen schwimmen. Ist schön. Ja, schwimmen war ja ja Platz zwei bei mir. Und es ist schön warm. Es ist schönes Geräusch auch, wenn es verdampft. Warm? Es ist schön warm. Wasserdampf ist schön warm. Als kleine Überraschung, als kleiner Upset wahrscheinlich jetzt bei mir tatsächlich Platz eins der Aggregatszustände von Wasser ist Eis. Nein! Doch, Eis. Nein! Rittschulaufen macht Spaß, Eis ist glatt, ist schön anzusehen, Eis essen macht Spaß, ist lecker. Wir brauchen die Gletscher, vergess die Gletscher nicht. Nur weil du so viel Wasserdampf verbraucht hast mit Elektronik und Kohle und allem, schmelzen die Gletscher weg. Und dann wollen wir mal sehen, was wichtiger ist, das Eis in Gletscherform oder dein fucking Wasserdampf, der die ganze Welt kaputt macht. Ist auch lustig, wie sehr man Wasser eigentlich mag und auch braucht zum Trinken, zum Überleben und so. Aber viel Wasser ist so scheiße. Dann ist bei mir auch, hat es reingeregnet und so weiter und natürlich bei weitem nicht so schlimm, was sonst passiert ist. Aber holy shit, wie schlecht Menschen auf mehr Wasser als üblich vorbereitet sind, wenn es mal ein bisschen mehr regnet, ist insane. Man fühlt sich so unsicher, wenn es plötzlich so von der Decke getropft und reinregnet. Aber schon erstaunlich, wie präzise die Menge an Wasser auf der Erde überhaupt ist. Weil ich meine, dass es gerade so passt und wenn es ein bisschen steigt, ist Riesenkatastrophe, aber es passt genau.
Wir können ja auch auf der Erde leben, wo einfach der Wasserstand zehn Meter höher ist und wir hätten irgendwie zwei, zwanzig Quadratkilometer Platz, wir Menschen. Aber nein, es ist so präzise. Ist es Zufall oder ist es durch irgendeine Wechselwirkung, dass es genau so ist, dass gerade so die Hälfte der Erde Wasser ist und der Rest nicht? Es ist reiner Zufall. Reiner Zufall? Reiner Zufall. Du hast ja eh gesagt, Meeresgrund wegbomben, damit da einfach ein bisschen mehr Platz entsteht und das Wasser abläuft.
Ja.
Hast du nicht gesagt, schönen Atombomben auf dem Meeresgrund ballern?
Ich habe gesagt, das war eine Kampagne von mir, mit Atombomben auf dem Meeresgrund,ern. Ich habe gesagt, das war eine Kampagne von mir, Erd mit Atombomben auf dem Meeresgrund,
nieder mit dem Meeresgrund
war der Claim,
runter mit dem Meeresgrund.
Ja. Weil ich dachte, wenn wir
so ein bisschen Erde wegballern,
erst mal nimmt man die grosse Bagger.
Aber jetzt stellt sich raus,
das ist ja ein sehr tief und so.
Ich denke mal, warum sickert es nicht ab?
Warum sickert es nicht in den Erdkern rein? Ja, das ist eine gute Frage. Müssen wir nicht einfach nur ein langes Loch bohren, dass das ganze Wasser in den Erdkern geht und dann verdampft und dann nach oben blubbert? Und diese Energiegreifung ist noch ab für unseren Strom. Ehrlich jetzt. Aber dann wird Wasser, man kann ja Wasser nicht vernichten, das ist ja dann immer wieder Wasserdampf und regnet dann runter oder so. Wir werden es hier nicht los, ne? Naja, außer wir bomben den Meeresboden weg, weil dann kann es ja nach unten abfließen. Ja, ich glaube, das war auch so in etwa dann der Kreis, den ich gegangen bin, um dann dabei zu landen, dass wir den Meeresgrund wegballern. Aber auch der landet ja letztlich dann wieder, also den müssen wir dann ins Weltall tragen, den Meeresgrund. Nee, das vaporisiert ja so. So eine Atombombe, die zappt das alles. Ist das so? Die Erde ist ein System, was nichts verliert an Energie? Weißt du, was es helfen würde? Weißt du was? Ein Physikkurs für Kinder vielleicht? Nee, ich habe die Idee. Und zwar, wenn es jetzt so warm wird in den nächsten Jahren, und wir haben auch zu viel Wasser hier, dann nutzen wir das Ganze und schlagen zwei Fliegen mit einer Klappe, aber eine große Klappe. Wir bohren den Erdkern, wie du gerade gesagt hast, das Wasser fliesst da rein, wir bohren den genau da, dass quasi uns auch so tief, dass so viel Wasser reinfließt, wie wir gerade zu viel haben, wegen Fluten und so, und nutzen dann, weil das müsst ihr euch ja vorstellen wie so einen Auspuff, wo dann der Wasserdampf wird rausgeschossen, aus dem Erdkern wieder raus, und treibt die Erde so ein bisschen von der Sonne weg. So ein Mühe. Ich verstehe. So ein Mühe. Ja, wie so ein Motor. Ein bisschen weiter wechseln. Es gibt halt das kleine Problem, dass die Erde sich dreht
und halt dadurch
dein Antrieb, wenn der immer in die gleiche
Richtung geht, dann schlängert der eigentlich
uns nur so durch die Gegend.
Es ist wie so, wenn man die ganze Zeit auf einem
Karussell leben würde.
Ich glaube, der Name Tietze würde
in den nächsten Jahren eher
in Verruf geraten, wenn das dazu führt, dass wir alle wie in so einem Karussell leben. Das macht, glaube ich, ein Jahr lang mega Spaß, mega Bock. Aber danach, glaube ich, wird es ein bisschen länger.
Ich glaube, es macht zwei Minuten mega Bock.
Als ich jetzt neulich im Phantasmann noch mal war, fährt eine Achterbahn, von der man immer sagt, ich kann nicht genug bekommen, oh nein, ich möchte lieber nochmal fahren,uh, wuh. Nach zwei Minuten dreissig, trust me, macht keinen Bock mehr, die war zu lang. Als wir in New York das Fourth of July Feuerwerk gemerkt haben, haben wir auch gedacht, oh, krass, die Halbwertszeit, die ich bereit bin, wie Feuerwerke zu ertragen, ist sehr klein.
Ich möchte nicht so lange, und das ist es, glaube ich, dann auch. Ich glaube, wenn man Karussell erlebt, wäre man, glaube ich, nach zwei Minuten runter. So, aber jetzt zurück zum Problem. Die Erde dreht sich, gut. Wir halten die mal kurz an. So, ja.
Ja, das ist ja kein Problem.
Ja, oder
man baut so ein Rohr,
was man so, wie so ein,
weißt du, wie man das hat
in einem U-Boot, wo man oben das Ding rausstückt.
So ein Periskop.
Und das kann man ja auch drehen, weißt du?
Wenn man sowas hat, hätte, also quasi aus dem Auspuff hinten
so ein großes Rohr reinmacht, was man dann in die Richtung lenkt,
wo man es haben will. Verstehe. Ja, das ist super. Finde ich gut. So machen wir es.
Ruf da mal an bei so einem Institut oder so. Ja, wo finden wir da an? Das ist doch hier in Köln, das ist in der
Nähe, hier im Mediapark. Ja, ich glaube, dass Fresenius ist nicht unbedingt dafür verantwortlich.
Das hat einen guten Namen, das klingt also nicht im Sinne von guter Ruf, aber halt einen coolen Namen.
Dann wäre ich wortwörtlich, der irgendwer die Welt lenkt.
Ja, das stimmt. Aber wer lenkt jetzt gerade die Welt?
Wer ist da am Lenkrad, ist die Frage. Wer sitzt da am Lenkrad?
Aber wer lenkt jetzt gerade die Geschicke der Welt?
Ja, das ist natürlich die Frage. Da wird sich ja auch einiges ändern jetzt bald.
Dann wird sich was ändern, aber ich frage mich jetzt, um diesen Prozess zu starten, muss ich ja wissen, wer jetzt gerade die Erde lenkt. Und dann musst du Shotgun schreien, um möglichst dann zumindest mal schon mal auf dem Beifahrersitz zu sitzen. Lenkt Jeff Bezos Steven, ich weiß nicht, Jeff Bezos die Welt? Steve Bezos. Lenkt Steve Bezos die Welt? Gerade, weil dann müsste ich nämlich zu ihm gehen und sagen, nee, ich würde jetzt mal ans Lenkrad. Schau mal, geh mal bei ihm vorbei, frag da mal an. Ich glaube, der hat ein offenes Ohr für deine Lenkeridee. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich habe ein offenes Ohr, aber ein sehr abgeschlossenes Gebäude. Ja. Ja, schwierig. Die Probleme der Welt liegen da, niemand löst sie. Wir lösen sie hier jede Woche. Ja, was heißt lösen? Ich fand es interessant, wir haben ja letzte Woche den Clowns-Beruf beerdigt, quasi, weil wir gesagt haben, Clowns sind furchtanflössend. Und eigentlich können wir nicht nachvollziehen, warum es Clowns überhaupt noch gibt als Unterhaltungsmaterial. Und ich habe erwartet, dass da wirklich ein bunter Tortenregen auf uns niederfährt nach dieser Folge. Stellt sich raus, nichts. Niemand hat widersprochen. Nicht mal die Clowns selbst. Ich glaube, wir haben eine Menge Clowns-Hörer. Aber die sagen ja nichts. Wir haben eine Menge gestikuliert, aber das kommt halt schlecht an. Das kommt schlecht an bei einem Audio-Medium. Das stimmt schon. Das heißt, niemand hat das widersprochen. Das ist ja so ein bisschen mein Reality-Check. Ich behaupte erst mal was im Podcast, gucke, ob Gegenwind kommt und dann setze ich es erst politisch um. Also wenn ich wirklich merke, oh, da ist niemand wirklich dagegen, dann versuche ich Clowns abzuschaffen, als politisches Programm zu etablieren. Also, ich gebe jetzt ein bisschen Einblick hinter die Kulissen meines politischen Systems. Oder jedes politischen Systems. Oh, spannend. Ja? Führ das mal weiter aus. Ach, bitte nicht. Opportunismus würde man es einfach n, Populismus. Ja, genau. Und deswegen, keine Clowns haben sich beschwert. Also ich glaube, Clowns sind auch dabei, sich selber zu beerdigen und haben es eingesehen. Und ja, wir müssen gucken, was wir mit diesen Leuten machen. Jokes on them. Yep. Cake on them. Cake on them, jokes on them, right? Ja, ehrlich gesagt hat es mich auch schockiert. Auf der anderen Seite, ja, okay, mach das mal, bring das mal jetzt durch. Ich schreibe das mal in mein Programm und wer Bock hat, mich zu wählen, kann mich ja wählen. Wie gesagt, ich werde nicht. Habt ihr auch noch andere Programmpunkte oder ist das primär der Programm? Naja, also wir gucken mal, wie es läuft, wenn wir im Bundestag sind. Wir haben dann auch ein bisschen mehr Manpower und dann wird das schon. Also wie gesagt, wir stehen nicht auf dem Wahlzettel, da haben wir leider die Frist verpasst.
Aber ihr könnt gerne.
Eure Logo ist schon sehr eins zu eins einfach eine rote Nase durchgestrichen, ne? Ja, aber gut, Rot kommt ja nicht so gut rüber auf dem Schwarz-Weiss-Wahlzettel, deswegen, das haben wir leider ein bisschen verbockt. Nicht ich, aber jemand aus meiner, meinem Team. Und ich sag nur so, wir sind auf dem Wahlzettel nicht vertreten, aber es hindert euch niemand daran, da ein weiteres Kästchen einzuschreiben. Das Gesetz. Und dann das anzukreuzen. Und dann wollen wir mal sehen, wie wir es denen da oben mal endlich zeigen. Ja, den Leuten, die die Erde lenken. Kleinstpartei. Kleinstpartei. Herr Weh, Sie wissen schon, dass Sie gerade quasi einen Aufruf zum Wahlbetrieb haben. Nein, ich habe gesagt, Sie haben keinen Aufruf gemacht. Ich habe nur gesagt, es ist eine Möglichkeit, die die Wähler... Sie haben gesagt, bitte machen Sie das. Unten in Neukästen. Die Wähler nutzen... Lassen Sie mich jetzt ausreden. Also bin ich jetzt hier, um zu reden oder um Ihre Fragen nur anzuhören? Bitte. So. Und ich habe nur gesagt, dass es eine Möglichkeit ist für alle Leute, die es eine Frechheit finden, dass wir die Frist verpasst haben, um uns offiziell ins Wahlregister einzuschreiben, haben die Möglichkeit, rein theoretisch hier uns auf den Wahlzettel zu schreiben und dann zu wählen. Ja, das Wahlbetrug und das ist offensichtlich verboten. Das sagen Sie. Das Gesetz sagt uns, Herr Will. Das sagen Sie. Okay, können Sie aufhören, mit dieser Blume in mein Gesicht zu spritzen, okay? Ich sehe ein, dass Clowns nervig sind. Brauchen Sie mir nicht noch beweisen. Aha, jetzt haben Sie es selber gesagt. Können wir die Kamera da drauf? Nee. Können wir die Kamera auf Ihnen lenken? Unser Studio, bitte können wir die Kamera auf Ihnen lenken, bitte? Ja, ich habe gesagt, dass es etwas nervig ist, aber ich weiß jetzt nicht genau, warum Sie jetzt in den Bundestag dafür einkehren müssen. Ich glaube, alle sind sich einig, dass Clowns ziemlich nervig sind. Wie viele Leute kommen jedes Jahr bei Verkehrsunfällen ums Leben? Sehr viele, zu viele. Richtig. Wie viele Clowns passen in ein Auto? Gott, zum Himmel. So, da müssen Sie doch eine einfache Plus- und Minusrechnung anstellen, um zu wissen, dass wenn Clowns abgeschafft werden, wesentlich weniger Leute in Autounfällen ums Leben kommen.
Wenn man einen Clown aus Auto und Unfall baut, dann sind 50 Leute perdu.
Das war Flo und den Will von der Clownspartei. Wir freuen uns nächste Woche auf unseren weiteren Gast, der Türen abschaffen will. Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen und bis nächste Woche. Apropos Türen, ich habe eine neue Phase. Ist das wieder nur eine Phase? Ich habe eine neue Phase, ich weiß, ist ein bisschen out of character, aber ich habe eine neue Phase, und zwar ich habe eine neue Sportart für mich entdeckt. Nicht, dass ich sie machen würde, aber ich schaue sie an auf YouTube. Ach so, okay. Ich schaue sie an auf YouTube, und zwar meine Sportart der Woche ist Paddel. Paddel! Kenne ich natürlich, El Paddel. Du kennst El Paddel? Si, si. Alter, das ist die beste fucking Sportart der Welt. Ich glaube, es ist eine Sportart aus Spanien, richtig? Jetzt ist es eine Sportart aus Spanien. Stellt euch vor, im Grunde ist es Tennis. Tennis 2v2. Aber, by the way, wo du es gerade erzählt hast, amazed bin ich davon, dass es immer noch Sportarten erfunden werden können. Unglaublich. Unglaublich. Aber da bin ich wirklich dabei, wo ich sage, ja, schmeißt Snooker weg, schmeißt Golf weg, wir brauchen mehr neue Sport an und Paddel ist der Beweis, dass die Innovationskraft nicht versiegt. Es ist im Grunde Tennis, zwei v zwei, aber da, wo das Tennisfeld normalerweise aufhören würde, wo der Ball im Aus wäre, da hört das Feld nicht auf, sondern da gibt es einen großen Glaskasten um das Feld herum, das heißt, da kann der Ball nochmal abprallen, wieder zurück ins Feld und. Das Squash-Prinzip. Aber bei Squash ist es ja so, dass der Kasten abgeschlossen ist. Bei Paddel ist das nicht der Fall. Da ist der Kasten nämlich nur ungefähr so drei Meter hoch. Das heißt, der Ball kann rein theoretisch auch über diesen Glaskasten aus dem Feld rausfliegen. Aber dann ist das Spiel noch nicht vorbei. Nein, nein, nein. Dieser Glaskasten hat auf der Höhe des Netzes eine Tür, wo der Spieler aus dem Glaskasten rauswetzen kann, um dann außerhalb des Kastens den Ball wieder in den Kasten reinzuspielen. Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment. Und das hat mich sofort überzeugt. Muss er draußen, kann er auf ein Auto fallen, der Ball? Nein, das Tolle ist, der Glaskasten ist das Spielfeld, aber drumherum gibt es nochmal einen grossen Umkreis, was auch noch zum Spielfeld gehört. Das heißt, der VW Käfer, der da geparkt hat, auf dem Park, das mit dem Kennzeichen K9324, der gehört auch noch dazu. Da kann der Padelier nochmal drauf drauf springen. Offensichtlich keine Buchstaben mehr. Das heißt, wenn da der Paddellball draufballert, kannst du noch rausrennen durch die Tür, musst du erst den neunzeiligen Code eingeben, kannst die Tür aufmachen, musst du den innerhalb einer gewissen Zeit machen. Nee, bevor er auf den Boden kommt, glaube ich. Ich glaube, bevor der Ball auf den Boden kommt, musst du den raushalten. Und das ist fantastisch, weil wir alle lieben ja diese Momente im Sport, wenn der Ball irgendwie ausserhalb der normalen Sphäre kommt. Man kennt das beim Basketball, wo der Basketballspieler in das Publikum springt, um den Ball nochmal zurück ins Feld zu werfen. Oder beim Volleyball auch, wo der Ball ganz weit weg fliegt. Oder bei der spannendsten Sport der Welt, Baseball, wo ein Kind plötzlich mit seinem großen Nix-Handschuh so ein Ball drauf fällt und niemand weiß, was passiert. Und der Spieler in die U-Bahn steigt und ausserhalb des Stadions fährt und Ball da zu fangen. Also das sind die Momente, für die ich lebe im Sport, wo Grenzen überschritten werden. Und davon lebt Paddel. Davon lebt Paddel, weil das, erst als ihr das Spielfeld gesehen habt, dachte ich, okay, das passiert regelmäßig, deswegen reservieren die diesen ganzen Platz um das Spielfeld, aber das passiert unglaublich selten, aber trotzdem gibt es dieses System, dass wenn der Spieler merkt, oh, der Ball fliegt hinter mir aus dem Feld, ich muss nach vorne laufen zur Tür und muss um einmal drum herum, um den Ball zu treffen, und allein diese Idee, dass es eine Sportart gibt mit einer Tür, hat mich fasziniert. Wir alle kennen Tore. Klar, Tore sind im Sportgang und gäbe. Aber ich glaube, es gibt nur einen Sport mit einer Tür. Es gibt eins, zwei oder drei, da spielen Tür eine Rolle, und Paddel, wo man zur Tür rauswetzen muss, um den Ball wieder reinzuschlagen. Aber ist jetzt... Grossoeitig. Schaut euch das mal auf YouTube an. Ja, wo guckst du das? Es ist wahrscheinlich schwer zu erklären. YouTube, ich habe das einmal gesehen, dass der Ball rausfliegt, dachte ich, geil. Schau ich mir das Paddelmatch an und im gesamten Match ist das kein einziges Mal passiert, dass der Außenfeld rausfliegt. Weil, jetzt guck mal, es muss ja auf allen Paddelfelden der Welt Feldern, muss ja quasi, müssen sich ja Profi-Padellisten quasi zu Hause fühlen. Ja. Um halt maximale Professionalität und Spielkunst an den Tag zu legen. Genau. Sind die Türen genormt? Ich glaube, die müssen genormt sein und da ist auch in weiser Voraussicht so Schaumstoffprotektoren an der Tür. Weil man sich dachte, okay, jemand muss ganz schnell durch diese kleine Tür wetzen, da wird es wahrscheinlich auch Compilations geben, wie Leute da dagegen rennen, und es gibt tolle Compilations zu Paddel, weil bei dem Spiel, habe ich das Gefühl, gehen ständig Sachen schief, weil manchmal liegt der Ball auch auf diesem Glaskasten oben da auf, und dann müssen die Spieler, wie wenn so, wie wenn der Ball so im Baum hängt und die mit dem Paddel aber das ist das Tolle, das ist so super bei neuen Sportarten geht noch nicht alles glatt, Dinge werden nach und nach perfektioniert, die Fußballregeln sind ja tausende Millionen Jahre alt ja genau, das ist noch gut da gehen noch Dinge passieren nochmal weird da kann man noch cheaten und explo Sachen finden und, Moment mal, kann nicht einer von uns beiden im Publikum sitzen und dann irgendwie dem Schiedsrichter eine drüber paddeln, während der sagt, das wäre abseits? Naja, es steht nicht in den Regeln, dass es verboten ist. Unsere Regeln sind eine, die da vier Seite. Aber du hast schon recht, jetzt beim Erklären ist es schwierig. Ich habe mich gerade gefragt, warum es so schwierig ist. Ich glaube, weil physikalische Gesetze in meinem Kopf anders sind als in der Realität. Weil jetzt erklärst du mir das und in meinem Kopf ist die Schwerkraft augenscheinlich viel stärker, weil es gibt für mich kein Szenario, wo der Ball so steil hochgehen kann und so lange, dass du es schaffst zu merken, ah, der Ball fliegt gerade jetzt aus dem Kasten heraus, ich
gehe entspannt zur Tür, mach die Tür
auf, lauf um den ganzen riesigen Glaskasten
auf diesem 19x19 Meter Feld
rum, um dann noch aus der Luft
den scheiß Ball ins
gegnerische Feld, das
physikalische, das funktioniert in meinem Kopf nicht so.
Aber es geht, ich glaube, man muss, der Ball
muss erstmal die gegnerische Spielfeldhälfte
berühren, weil sonst könntest du den Ball ja einfach
mit voller Wucht aus dem Stadion schießen,
aber du musst den erst auf dem gegnerischen Feld
Vielen Dank. Aber es geht. Ich glaube, der Ball muss erst mal die gegnerische Spielfeldhälfte berühren, weil sonst könntest du den Ball ja einfach mit voller Wucht aus dem Stadion schießen. Aber du musst den erst auf dem gegnerischen Feld aufdotzen lassen und dann, vor allem der Spieler merkt ja dann schon, oh, der Winkel ist steil, rennt schon raus. Und das habe ich auch in einem Tutorial gesehen, weil da erklärt so einen Paddlehrer, wie man Paddle spielt. Und er hat gesagt, rennen Sie erst mal zur Tür raus und gucken dann, wo der Ball ist. Mehr Respekt, wenn du jetzt schon Padell-Lehrer bist. Das ist ein Commitment. Man muss nur der Erste sein eigentlich. Der muss ja auch nicht gut sein. Bei der neuen Sportart ist es ja okay, wenn du jetzt mal ein scheiß Trainer bist. Du bist ja automatisch der Beste, wenn du es halt einmal schon mal gespielt hast bei der neuen Sportart. Das ist wie dieses Mädchen, das im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde ist für den ältesten Tamagotchi. Das war halt einfach die, die den ersten Tamagotchi gekauft hat. Das ist der älteste. Und die hat da nichts grosses dafür geleistet, sondern war halt einfach die erste. Aber das ist wirklich kranios. Obwohl ich muss immer sagen, ich bin skeptisch gegenüber Sportarten, die man nicht einfach auf dem Bolzplatz spielen kann. So, das ist viel zu komplex. Du brauchst diesen Glaskasten und du brauchst diese Türe und du brauchst das alles so.
Ich glaube, Sportarzen setzen sich nur grossflächig durch, wenn du einfach sagen kannst, die Kinder spielen das mit einer Dose und einem Ball auf dem Spielplatz. So Fußball oder... Es gibt in Köln zwei Paddellplätze, das weiß ich, von der Uni. Echt? Da gehen Kumpels von mir regelmäßig hin und haben mich schon ein paar Mal gefordert, wenn ich mitkommen will, aber hat noch nie gepasst. Moment mal, du bist schon fast drin im Paddel. Ich bin super, ich war schon fast drin.
Ich wollte aber immer gesagt, nee, sag mir Bescheid, wann ihr Beechten geht, weil ich will ja Beachvolleyball spielen. Achso, ich dachte, es gibt noch einen Beachvolleyball. Dann haben die mir Bescheid gesagt, wann sie Paddel spielen gehen, weil hier in der Uni Köln wohl Paddelplätze sind. Alter, wollen wir mal Paddel spielen? Wir können gerne mal Paddel spielen. Praktisch auch allein aus so einer Rundfunksicht, du kannst sehr gut durchfilmen durch diese Glaswand. Ja, perfekt. Perfekt. Ich hab mir auch gedacht, das kann man gut filmen, ist richtig gut und der Zuschauer checkt eh nicht genau, was passiert, also von daher kann man immer jubeln und sagen, wow, toller Schuss. Solange es noch neu ist, einfach eine wow, mega Sportart. Ja, aber auch diese physikalischen Gesetze, dieses Hindernis hab ich auch im Kopf, wenn ich an Squash denke. Ich kann mir Squash, wenn ich spiele,
verstehe ich, dass es funktioniert.
Ich nehme die Erdangstungskraft als solche wahr und checke,
wie es ist. Aber ich kann mir keinen
Squash-Ballwechsel in meinem Kopf
vorstellen. Geht nicht.
Du musst da ultra komplex denken. Wie soll denn der
Ball so abpallen,
dass er nicht die ganze Zeit wie so ein Flur
durch das ganze Gebäude fliegt,
dass der andere nach einem Mal auftischen
noch zurückspielen kann? Like how the fuck
Vielen Dank. Ball so abpallen, dass er nicht die ganze Zeit wie so ein Flummi durch das ganze Gebäude fliegt, dass der andere nach einem Mal auftischen noch zurückspielen kann. Like how the fuck? Weil die hauen ja richtig doll drauf auf den Ball. Ja, ich glaube, deswegen ist es auch so schwer zuzuschauen, weil das meiste passiert so im räumlichen Vorstellungsvermögen und man denkt sich nicht, ja die paddeln da halt hin und her. Man muss dazu sagen, Paddel wird auch gespielt mit Paddeln. Also nicht mit Tennisschlägern, sondern mit Paddeln, sprich mit, die kennt man vielleicht vom Strand, diese grauenhaften Strandschläger, die einfach massiv sind, aus Keramik. Einen sehr schlechten Paddel zu Hause. Also wirklich, wenn ich ab und zu am Strand bin und Leuten dabei zuschaue, wie sie mit diesem Paddel und dem Ball spielen, es ist immer dasselbe. Aufschlag, Sand. Oh, ich laufe hin. Aufschlag, Sand. Noch nie kam ein Spieler mit zustande.
Ich habe es noch nie gesehen.
Es ist immer die Tochter und die Mutter
und die beiden ballern überall hin
und noch nie kam Ball weg zustande.
Ich und meine Tochter
haben schon mal
bis 200 geschafft.
Wirklich, das kann ich nicht. Aber dann wirklich so
kniehoch im Meer oder am Strand?
Nee, am Strand. Am Kniehoch im Meer keine Chance.
Man bewegt sich,
auch das kann ich mir nicht richtig vorstellen,
... Wirklich, das kann ich mir nicht. Aber dann wirklich so kniehoch im Meer oder am Strand? Nee, am Strand. Kniehoch im Meer keine Chance.
Man bewegt sich, auch das kann ich mir nicht richtig vorstellen, weil, again, die physikalischen Gesetze in meinem Kopf funktionieren anders, leicht anders, subtil anders, aber im Meer stehend kannst du dich nicht gut fortbewegen. Das Meer hält dich auf. Nee, aber Beachball macht keinen Sinn, weil es kein Spiel ist. Es ist wie so ein Zusammen...
Man spielt zu zweit gegen niemanden, ausser gegen die Gravitation, mit sich selbst. Man ist in einem Team und verliert immer. Wohingegen mag ich lieber Spiele, die ein bisschen kompetitiv sind. Paddel klingt toll. Ich hätte Lust auf Paddel, aber man kann es tatsächlich nur zwei vor zwei spielen, was ich schade finde, weil es schon mal die Hälfte der Sportbegeisterten ausschließt und ich auch kein Spielfan bin.
Auch bei der Olympia habe ich mir das immer nicht gerne angeguckt, diese Teamsportarten, weil ich mir immer dachte, so dann Volleyball und dann schießt der eine den Volleyball ins Aus und dann denke ich mir immer der andere, mein du Trottel, man schießt es doch nicht ins Aus, so du Depp, du weißt doch, wo die Linie ist und der so sorry, sorry. Ich will mich ständig entschuldigen.
Ja, genau.
Ich will nicht wissen, wer der Beste mit dem grössten Trottel im Team ist.
Genau.
So, ich will wissen, wer ist der beste Spieler, beste Spielerin in dieser Sportart. Bei einem Team denke ich mir, okay, da ist es dann irgendwie so, dann ist es eine andere Leistung, aber ich habe immer das Gefühl, bei jedem zwei vor zwei, der eine kann es, der andere kommt halt mit, weil er der nächstbeste war. Und du hast diesen einen krassen Typen, der halt leider in einem Land lebt, wo der Nächstbeste halt einfach ein Trottel ist und der muss dann irgendwie durchs Turnier ziehen. Wann haben Leute aufgehört, Versus zu sagen? Statt V. V? Du hast ja schon so gesagt, zwei V2. Das ist für mich neu, weil in meiner Welt haben noch alle Versus gesagt. Vielleicht kommt es aus dem E-Sport, aus Videospielen. Da sagt man eher PvP, zwei V2. Oldschool gegen. Zwei gegen zwei. Versus ist das coolste Wort der englischen Sprache. Und das müssen wir auch nutzen, so oft es geht. Versus. Du kürzt es ab mit V. Tatsächlich sage ich V. Vogel V. Vogel V, tatsächlich ein kleines Vogel V. Zwei Vogel V zwei. Ja, kommt vielleicht aus dem Gaming. Ich bin ja ein Gamer, ich bin ja ein leidenschaftlicher Gamer, ich liebe es ja zu daddeln und zu zocken. Und da kommt das ja vielleicht her. Ja, also ganz ehrlich, Twitch wollte ich auch mal machen, starten hat es bislang noch nicht, habe ich noch nicht geschafft, weil ich keinen Windows-Rechner und keine Gaming-Skills habe. Von daher ist das Projekt
erst mal noch auf Eis gelegt.
Auf Eis gelegt? Aha.
Aber heißt auf Eis gelegt,
heißt eigentlich eher konservieren, oder?
Also man liegt ja...
Auf Wiedervorlage gelegt.
Auf Wiedervorlage.
Ich habe einen ersten Hilfekurs gemacht
und der bestand zu 10%
darin zuzuhören.
Du hast einen ersten Hilfekurs gemacht.
Was du mal das machen soll,
das im Raumleben machen, der erste Hilfekurs.
Das ist ein, was ich. einen Hilfekurs gemacht und der bestand zu zehn Prozent darin zuzuhören. Du hast einen ersten Hilfekurs gemacht. Was du mir das machen soll, das im Raum leben an, der erste Hilfekurs. Der Ersthelferkurs. Ja, und der bestand für mich zu zehn Prozent darin zuzuhören und zu neunzig Prozent darin mir vorzustellen, wie zur Hölle man das mit diesem abgetrennten Körperteil und dem Eis irgendwie praktikabel hinkriegt. Eis ist nicht in Hülle und Fülle vorhanden. Richtig. Du musst, wenn jemand ein Körperteil verliert, musst du das in Plastik tun und das dann wieder in einen Sack mit Eiswasser tun, damit es gekühlt wird. Und ich dachte mir nur so, no fucking way hat das schon jemals in der Geschichte der ersten Hilfe jemanden. Ich kann mir schon keinen Cocktail machen, weil ich nie zu Hause, selbst zu Hause nie Eis hatte. Nie. Oder auch dann nicht das richtige Verhältnis. Genau, du tust zu viel rein und es schmeckt nach Eis, oder du tust zu wenig rein und es ist warm. Du hast mich gerade verloren bei Eiswasser. Ja genau. Ich dachte eher, choose one. Richtig, dann haben die nämlich auch gesagt, tut den abgetrennten, irgendwie Daumen, wahrscheinlich meistens diesen Finger oder so, tut das nicht in Eis direkt, weil dann wird man so Mr. Freeze-mässig, kriegt man so Eiskräfte und das ist zu kalt. Und das wollen die nicht, weil das ist versicherungstechnisch super schwierig. Deswegen haben die gesagt, nicht direkt in Eis bitte, sondern in Wasser, in das ihr Eis getan habt. Und die haben mir, okay, ich bin in der Situation, in der ich sowohl Eis als auch Wasserzugang habe, als auch mindestens zwei Plastiktüten. Aber jetzt wird es wirklich so... Was passiert da? Jetzt wird es wirklich langsam so Cocktail-artig. Weil es wird ja auch schick. Angenommen, du machst so ein bisschen Wasser rein in so ein Glas, auch ein schönes Glas, so ein Nachtmann-Glas vielleicht. Du machst dann so einen Daumen da rein, dann wird es auch das Blut, so ein bisschen so eine schöne Röte. Oh ja, ja, genau. Und dann machst du noch so zwei Eiswürfel rein, weil du weißt ja nicht, wie viel. Und bitte, tun Sie noch so einen kleinen Schirm rein, damit der Notarzt weiß, welche Blutgruppe das ist. Nehmen Sie so einen kleinen Schirm und schreiben Sie da die Blutgruppe drauf. Aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass das jemals passiert ist. Ich glaube auch, wenn du wirklich ins Krankenhaus gehst und sagst, hier mein Kumpel hat ein Paddelspiel, den Daumen verloren, hier ist der Daumen in der Plastiktüte, sagt der, kach, verarsch mich nicht. Nein, das war ein Prank von uns. Nein, da ist jetzt eine Wurst drin oder so. Da ist echt der Daumen, wirklich. Ihr seid die Ersten, der kommt gar nicht zum Operieren, der ist völlig ausser sich, ihr seid die Ersten, die das jemals tatsächlich gemacht haben. Eine Freundin von mir hat mal ihre Zähne verloren bei einem Fahrradunfall, so richtig doll aufgetitscht, oberste Zahnreihe waren weg. Oh Gott, alle? Und dann hat sie in so einer Art Schock einen befreundeten Arzt angerufen, der gesagt hat, und wir wissen besorgt nicht, ob es ein Prank war oder nicht, du musst die im Mund lassen, weil sonst kann man die nicht
wieder dran bauen. Und dann haben die die,
hat sie die im Mund gelassen.
Moment, aber die waren rausgefallen und dann hat sie sie
wieder reingesteckt. Um Gottes Willen.
Abgetrennt so oben. Dann hat die die wieder
in den Mund gepackt.
Was ich verstehe, so im alten
Habitat. Habitat.
Ja, ja, genau. So im alten Habitat hast du noch die Zähne. Da fühlen die sich wohl. Da waren die lange, da fühlen die sich wohl, die kennen es so, die mögen es so. Ist dann mit diesen Zähnen dann in so einem Bar gelaufen, damit die schnell in die Krankenbarger anrufen oder sowas. Und dann ist sie zu einer Kieferchirurgie gefahren, wovor ihr jemand mit einer Gabel im Auge wirklich eine Gabel im Auge hatte. Bei einer Kieferchirurgie? Ne, das war noch im Krankenhaus. Achso, das ist schon so. Sie sind hier völlig falsch. Sorry, völlig falsch. Sorry, ich sehe es sehr schlecht. Ich konnte das Schild nicht lesen. Das war noch im Krankenhaus, sie kam aber eher dran, weil sie privat versichert war, kam sie vor dem Typen mit der Gabel im Auge dran, mit ihren Zähnen, die noch im Mund waren, ist dann hingegangen, die hat gesagt, sie sind hier falsch, sie müssen in die Kieferchirurgie. Dann ist sie in die Kieferchirurgie gefahren, währenddessen kam dann noch Gott sei Dank der Mann mit der Gabel im Auge dran. Sie ist hingefahren zur Kieferchirurgie und die haben gesagt, warum haben sie die alten Zähne noch da drin, haben die genommen und weggeworfen. Was ich denke, wahrscheinlich häufig der Fall ist. Warum muss man Dinge konservieren? Ich glaube auch, dass jeder Arzt, erste Vorlesung Medizin ist immer, wenn ein Patient fragt, was sie machen sollen und sie dies nicht wissen, sagen sie irgendwas. Wir alle kennen den Placeboeffekt, wenn der Patient denkt, es würde jetzt helfen, dass man XY macht, dann ist das gut für den.
Dann sagen sie erstens verstaucht. Falls das nicht passt, irgendwas anderes naheliegendes Improv-mäßig ist. Aber verstaucht passt erst mal. Ja, ich glaube, das ist wirklich besser, weil es ist ja furchtbar, seinem Patienten sagen zu müssen, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung, keine Ahnung. Ich würde dem wahrscheinlich auch sagen, ja, packen Sie das in Eis ein, mischen Sie das gut durch, aber versuchen Sie die Reihenfolge der Zähne beizubehalten, damit die nicht verwechselt werden beim Arzt. Und dann irgendwie sowas, dann kann der Patient sich darauf konzentrieren, dass er das macht und denkt nicht, oh fuck, ich habe gerade meine Zähne verloren. Ich stelle mir mal vor, wenn man irgendwie so einen Ausschlag hat und dann geht man zum Arzt und der weiss nicht, was es ist, dass der dann so eine Sinnkrise fällt und und erst mal so sehr viele Bücher wälzt, die ja alle Ärzte haben ja so eine Bücherwand hinter sich, dass man erst mal sagt, gehen Sie raus, gehen Sie raus und dann die Arzt-Teilfone kommen und so, gehen Sie, gehen Sie, gehen Sie, gehen Sie, dann macht sie die Praxis zu und dann kriegt man nach ein paar Monaten einen Anruf, was es dann war, weil der Arzt sich so mit so einer wilden Professorfrisur erst mal in sein Atelierelier zu rissen. Der hat ja immer noch so ein eigenes Büro.
Und da witzte er immer rein und wieder raus.
Sie haben Ausschlag am Bein.
Okay.
Rot oder gelb?
Gelb.
Wie lange schon?
Zwei, googeln Sie gerade?
Nein.
Schlagen Sie in Büchern nach?
Nein, ich brauche nur Abstand.
Vielleicht ist es infektiös.
Also ansteckend für Sie.
Ja, es juckt.
War das eine Frage, die Sie gestellt haben?
Okay, ja, tut mir leid, da müssen wir leider eincremen.
Tut mir leid, wir werden nicht umhinkommen, Ihnen eine deftige Creme Salbe zu verschreiben. Creme oder Salbe? Creme oder Salbe? Salbe, Salbe. Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Creme und Salbe? So, Sie nehmen jetzt das Rezept und ... Ich frage dich als Florentin, frage ich jetzt, was ohne nachzugucken ist der Unterschied. Aber warum Creme? Ich raff nicht, was mit Salbe passiert, wenn man es draufschmiert.
Wo geht das hin?
Feine, ja auch.
Hier rein, warum rein?
Wo geht das hin?
Weil du hast ja, also dein Arm ist ja arm.
Und dann, also der ist ja so.
Nee, aber stell dir mal bei McDonalds.
Aber wenn die Salbe reingeht, wo bleibt die denn dann?
Reines Blut, ja auch.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn man dir was spritzt, dann geht das in den Blutkreislauf, dann ist das da drin, dann hast du halt ein bisschen mehr Blut, technisch gesehen. Aber wenn du was reinsalbst, das muss ja was anderes dann wegdringen. Ich stelle dir mal so eine schöne Serviette vor. Eine Serviette? Eine Serviette. Ja. Serviette, sagen wir in Dortmund. Ist halt falsch. Ja, ist halt falsch. Dann stellst du dir vor und dann kaufst du dir Pommes bei McDonalds. So, und dann hast du da oben drauf diese Serviette. Ne? Die suppt ja dann auch durch. Die Serviette suppt durch. Die Serviette suppt durch. Oder wenn du jetzt so ein anderes Beispiel, ich gucke in ein fragendes Gesicht, so eine Papiertüte von McDonalds. Diese braune. Herr Doktor, können Sie mir andere... Herr Will, so eine braune Papiertüte hat man bei McDonalds, ja, ne? Machen Sie da jemals. Bei To-Go, ja, aber ich esse immer doch vor euch. Nein, To-Go. Okay, sagen Sie To-Go. Ich habe kein Auto, ich bin nicht im McDrive. So, jetzt haben Sie sich Chicken McNuggets geholt. Sechs oder neun. Oder Pommes, neun. Okay, gut, die große Packung. Oder so eine mittlere
Pommes. Süssauer oder
irrelevant gerade für das Szenario.
Gut. So, jetzt fahren Sie nach Hause
in Ihrem Auto. Ja.
Und kommen nach Hause.
Wie sieht die braune, die ehemals
hellblaue braune Plastiktüte
noch aus?
Es zerknittert ein bisschen.
Nein, die ist durchgesuppt.
Durchgesuppt? Da ist so viel Fett dran,
weil das aufgesaugt hat.
Das Papier hat es aufgesaugt.
Es ist dunkelbraun.
Ja, Sie haben recht.
Und wenn Sie die Salbe auf Ihre Haut schmieren,
dann zieht das ein
wie so Fett auf einem Löschblatt.
Aha.
Ja, ich glaube, jetzt verstehe ich, was Sie meinen. Und dann geht es ja da rein, wenn du dann Ausschlag hast, dann soll er nicht in die Blutbahn rein. Soll er da in die Zellen rein? Ich glaube, ich habe es verstanden und ich habe ein bisschen Hunger. Soll ich mit Donalds gehen? Ja. Während der Arbeitsabendung. Komm, lass uns rübergehen. Ich wohne direkt neben einem. Aber ich bin gespannt, falls ihr es tatsächlich schon mal geschafft habt, ein abgetrenntes Körperteil erfolgreich zu einem Arzt zu bringen, schreibt uns. Und falls ihr erste Hilfelehrer seid, erzählt ihr das und erwartet ihr allen Ernstes, dass das jemand beherrscht danach oder sagt man das nur der Vollständigkeit halber und wird das irgendwann rausgestrichen? Sagt man manche Dinge nicht einfach eh so, gut, dass wir es mal angesprochen haben, aber wenn es nicht passiert, weil das sagt man, dann kriegt man nicht mitgeteilt, diese Fussnote, dieses ist nicht so schlimm, wenn es nicht ist, kriegt man nicht so häufig gehört. In der Fahrschule kann man auch mal gesagt bekommen, so ist es okay, wenn ihr 12 Kilometer pro Stunde zu schnell fahrt. Aber ich fand es gerade gut, dass du gesagt hast, die
ist in eine Bar gegangen,
um dann jemanden anzurufen, weil da gibt es
ja genug Eiswürfel. Eigentlich ist ja das
eine supergute erste
Anlaufstelle nach einer Katastrophe, nach
einem Unfall. Geh in eine Bar, die haben
Wasser, die haben Eiswürfel, da hast
du Alkohol, ist auch gut. In jedem
Kriegsfilm kriegt man immer erstmal einen Schluck
aus dem Flachmann, wenn man eine Verletzung hat. Ja, oder so ein rohes Fleisch, was man sich auf die Wunde legt. Oder so eine Erbsen, so eine eingefrorene Erbsen. Hambas Erbsen, Erdnüsse hätte ich da. Gefrorene Erdnüsse? Nee, die sind mit Zimmertemperatur. Nee, dann nicht, dann passt es nicht zu dem. Ja, Entschuldigung, Eiswürfel haben wir da. Ja, ich nehme zwei.
Okay.
Geben Sie drei.
Ich habe ganz schlechte Erfahrungen mit Drinks gemacht.
Bist du so ein Drinktyp, so ein Cocktailtyp?
Richtiger Drinktyp.
Ich hatte mal eine ganz kurze Phase, in der ich A, Alkohol getrunken habe und B, gedatet habe. Und ich habe versucht, das zu kombinieren und hatte dann ein Tinder-Date in einer Bar und dachte mir, sei nicht dumm, überleg dir jetzt mal einen coolen Drink, den du bestellen kannst.
Was ist das? versuch das zu kombinieren und hatte dann ein Tinder-Date in einer Bar und dachte mir, sei nicht dumm, überleg dir jetzt mal einen coolen Drink, den du bestellen kannst, weil du willst natürlich, ich will natürlich nicht rüberkommen als jemand, der sein Leben lang noch keinen Alkohol getrunken hat und gerade das erste Mal in seinem Leben einen Drink bestellt. Was würde der nicht bestellen, so einen schönen Arnold Palmer. Da habe ich mir überlegt und ich habe in der Zeit gerade Madman geschaut, die Serie. Also das hätte ich in Arnold.
Und da Don Draper, der coolste Mann der Welt, bestätigte. Da habe ich mir überlegt und ich habe in der Zeit gerade Madman geschaut, die Serie. Also das hätte ich in Arnold fahren.
Und da Don Draper, der coolste Mann der Welt, bestellt ein Seven and Seven.
Und ich dachte mir einfach, geil, das klingt mega cool, bestell das, du bist einfach the shit, du hast das Date schon quasi gewonnen, wenn du das bestellst.
Und dann kam da irgendwie der Keeper und meinte, was wollt ihr und sie, ein kleines Wasser und ich, ich nehme Seven and Seven. Und der Barkeeper, was? Ja, aber genau so was. Was? Und ich ja, bis heute, und jetzt deine Einschätzung, ist das jetzt besonders cool, Cocktails zu bestellen, die der Barkeeper nicht kennt, oder ist es besonders uncool? Ganz ehrlich, besonders uncool? Ja, findest du, ich habe bis heute hader ich, ob das nicht ein megacooler Move war. Bis heute draper ich. Ich hätte gerne einen Drink aus den 60er Jahren, ach, den kennen sie gar nicht, ach gut, dann mache ich ihn selber. Nee, wie uncool. Also wenn du als Cocktail-Kenner, weil die, warum ist es uncool?
Weil du willst ja mit deiner Bestellung
suggerieren, dass du dich auskennst mit Cocktails und nicht zum
ersten Mal gerade einen Cocktail bestellst, was
aber nicht so schlimm wäre, ehrlich gesagt.
Ja. Aber angenommen, das ist deine Definition
von cool und du willst dich beeindrucken mit dem
Cocktail, den du bestellst, den du kennst.
So, dann gehst du, dann
kennst du dich ja auch mit Bargepflogenheiten aus
und weißt, wie beliebt der Seven and Seven ist. Ja. Dann gehst du ja nicht in diese x-beliebige Kackbar irgendwo in einer zöblicher Straße in Köln und sagst, ich kenne Seven and Seven. Aber heisst das nicht, dass du normalerweise in Bars frequentierst, die einen gehobeneren Standard haben? Ja, aber so jemand weiß ja, dass man in Sonderbar keinen Seven and Seven bekommt. Du outest dich ja trotzdem als jemand, der keine Ahnung hat, was er hier gerade tut. Das ist so wie jemand, der beim ersten Date irgendwie zu McDonalds geht und da Hummer bestellt. Oder was, sie haben keinen Hummer. Ja, genau. Das ist so, du bist einfach hier, du kennst dich aber gar nicht aus. Ja, würde man jetzt nicht sagen, oh, der ist aber cool, der verkehrt sonst eher bei Gosch. Ja, ja, okay, verstehe. Fuck, lange dachte ich mir, was für ein Trotteln, jetzt hatte ich wieder eine lange Phase, wo ich mir dachte, nee, eigentlich ist es schon cool. Und ich reisse dich wieder ins Loch. Und jetzt bist du wieder runter. Schreib gerne mal in die Kommentare, ob ihr es findet, dass es besonders cool ist oder besonders uncool. Was ist denn Seven and Seven? Und dann habe ich gesagt, Seven and Seven, er wusste nicht, was es ist, er hat gesagt, das ist Whisky mit Ginger Ale. Und er so, okay, gut, bringt mir das. Stellt sich heraus, es ist nicht Whisky mit Ginger Ale, es ist Whisky mit Seven Up. Weil es gibt einen Whisky, der hat irgendwie Seven im Namen und es gibt Seven Up und damit Seven and Seven. Das ist der Drink. Und ich habe irgendeinen weirden Drink getrunken, Whisky und Ginger Ale, die es vielleicht so gar nicht gab. Ich habe keine Ahnung. Danach ist er auf jeden Fall durch die Decke gegangen. Ich weiß aber nicht genau. Ja, wirklich? Wegen mir? Ich war der Trendsetter. Wegen dir, aber man, also Whisky und Ginger Ale, genau wie YouTube.
Wie gut das wäre, wenn du googelst und das ist der Florentin Will.
Das ist der Florentin Will.
Das ist einfach Whisky und Ginger Ale, das ist der Florentin Will.
Wir schauen mal kurz nach, wie der.
Der wurde nach mir benannt.
Whisky.
Aber es war, also, ich meine, mir ist es eh egal, für mich schmeckt eh jeder Alkohol wie Terpentin, also mir ist es eh völlig egal, was da gemischt wird.
Ich wollte halt einfach nur einen coolen, und ich finde es. Oh, man nennt den Horses Neck, was ehrlich gesagt, was cooler wäre als Seven in Seven. Horses Neck? Ja, aber auch mit ... Ich weiß nicht, ob das cool ist. Aber auch in eine Bar zu gehen, wo eine der beiden Zutaten Seven Up ist, in Deutschland in eine Bar zu gehen und zu sagen, ich hätte gerne Seven in Seven, das ist einfach ballsy as fuck. Ja, habe ich mir auch gedacht. Vor allem, das gab es
in den Sechzigern bei Don Draper schon.
Horsesnack ist
zum Beispiel Whisky oder Cognac
mit Ingwerlimonade, Ginger Ale.
Horsesnack.
Ich hätte gerne Horsesnack.
Bestellt das mal bei eurem nächsten Date
und guckt mal, was passiert.
Oder bestellt einfach, ich hätte gerne den Tietze.
Ich hätte gerne den Stefan Tietze.
Dann kommst du zurück, was? Aber ich hätte es doch geiler gefunden, wenn du dann impubisiert hättest und dir irgendeinen Cocktail ausgedacht hättest. Hast du ja dann auch im Prinzip... Ja, ich hatte grob, ich wusste, es ist Whisky mit irgendwas und hab dann einfach gedacht, was sieht so aus wie Whisky, weil ich dachte, man mischt nach Farben in Cocktails. Und dann hatte ich mir Whisky und Ginger Ale vielleicht, aber nein, Seven Up. Vielleicht ist das gut, keine Ahnung. Wem ich vertraue, ist Odo Niemon von dem Liebendkast Wohlstand für alle, weil der immer einen Drink in der Hand hat. Was ihn für mich zum größten Cocktailkenner, den ich kenne, nicht persönlich, aber ich gucke manchmal die Sachen von den beiden und da hat er immer einen anderen Drink und macht manchmal bei Instagram Tipps. Und da freue ich mich immer drüber und würde mich freuen, wenn er so ein Cocktailbuch rausbringt. Ja, ich habe auch letztens einen Film gesehen, auf Englisch heisst es Another Round mit Mats Mikkelsen. Und da mixen die in Tesseract. Tesseract, glaube ich, heisst der. Wo man, das finde ich ja immer ein bisschen weird, wo man dann immer noch so diese Orangenschale über den Glasrand reibt. Wo ich mir immer denke, das kann doch nichts bringen. Doch, das habe ich auch mal gemacht. Ich habe mal eine Margarita gemacht und dann nimmst du halt eine Limette oder eine Zitrone und machst das über den Glasrand. Aber mit der schalen Seite. Ach so, mit der schalen Seite, das verstehe ich auch. Oder nicht, also ich verstehe. Mit der richtigen Seite, mit der flüssigen Seite und machst dann auf dem Teller Salz und dann legst du es drauf und hast da so einen Salzrand. Ach so, wegen so dieses Tikia-Ding. Ja, ja, Margarita, wie gesagt. Ach so, okay, ja, keine Ahnung. Aber ich denke mir immer so, das kann doch, vor allem also diese Schalennummer, das habe ich ja nicht verstanden, weil wenn du eine Orange ableckst, das schmeckt ja auch nach nichts. Ja genau, und was häufig auch, was ich beobachte, auch bei Ole, ist, dass er dann so eine Orangenschale, ich wüsste gar nicht, wie ich die so haupt und abbekomme,
dass man sich so spiralt und dann macht
er die so da rein. Es ist nicht wie beim Geschenkpapier,
dass du so mit der Schere so drüber schaben musst,
wo auch noch nie jemand verstanden hat,
was genau da passiert physikalisch.
Hat das was mit Hitze
zu tun, wenn man das so reibt oder
was passiert da? Ja, und auch bei Crazy Stupid
Love macht Ryan Gosling
auch halt diesen Orangenschaltrick, aber dieses Selbstbewusstsein muss man auch mal haben, wo man sagt, ich schelle jetzt das Äußere einer Orange ab, mach das dann da rein, weiss genau, wie dick die Orangenschale sein muss, dass es sich auch noch spiralt, weiss, dass man das macht, weil das auch noch was schmeckt. Krass. Für mich, das ist otherworldly. Ich denke immer nur daran zurück, dass ich damals im Alter von zehn Jahren, ich war großer Leser des Simpsons Magazins und da gab es Schick uns dein Rezept für deinen Sommerdrink und du gewinnst einen Supersocker. Und mein Drink war irgendwie Zitronensaft mit Wasser und Cola und Zucker, halt irgendwie was Lächerliches. Und dann habe ich das aufgeschrieben und es war halt erbärmlich
kurz zu kurz. Und dann habe ich es halt
noch ein bisschen künstlich länger gemacht mit
erst mal das Wasser in den Kühlschrank für eine
Stunde rausnehmen, mischen, noch mal
Kühlschrank, alles nutzlos, nur um es zu strecken.
Und so kommen mir auch viele
Cocktailrezepte vor. Aber das wird doch die ganze Zeit gemacht.
Dass du sagst, reib noch
die Schale außen und dann
noch mal drüber und so. Das ist doch alles Bullshit. Ich sage ja nichts, dass das alles Oberflächlichkeit ist, aber natürlich lebt diese Barkultur auch von einem gewissen Stil, dass man halt Coolness mit reinbringt. Und halt so ein Drink, wenn du sagst, oh, bei dem Drink machst du, da zündest du noch die Orangenschale an und schmeißt die in den Drink und so, dann war cool. Das ist doch alles Show. Backen ja auch so, dieses ja okay, Brot backen, wow, riesen Kunst, ne am Ende ist es Mehl, Wasser und Hitze, so. Und jetzt, dann ist es halt umständlich zu sagen, wenn du zum Bäcker gehst, ich hätte gern Mehl, Wasser, Hitze, man sagt halt einfach, ich hätte gern Brot. Genau, das ist ein anderes Wort dafür. So, aber jetzt, natürlich Backkultur und neue Sachen und so, dann hat man so ein Rezept und da muss man es achtmal in den Kühlschrank packen, über zwei Tage lang. Und wenn sie in der Woche Brot haben wollen, müssen sie jetzt angefangen haben. Und wenn ich ein Rezept raushole, dann ist es für morgen oder heute. Ist es für jetzt. Es ist eigentlich primär für jetzt. Und du machst das Rezept und in der letzten Zeit steht, acht Stunden im Kühlschrank. Ich sage, ja Leute, hab ich nicht. Dann bin ich nicht. Wenn acht Stunden ist es vier Uhr nachts. Dann soll ich mir den Wecker stehen oder was? Diese Voraussicht, die denken, die man hätte. Nee, Bullshit. Bullshit. Bullshit, macht kein Mensch. Macht kein Mensch. Null. Mach ich nicht mehr. Aber du machst Brot oder wie? Gar nicht. Nee, ich wollte, habe es sein gelassen. Ist zu viel Aufwand. Ich bin jetzt kein, nee, vor allem sind mir auch zu viele, aber die sind Trend aufgesprungen. Weil meine Phasen ist ja auch immer ein bisschen so, die sind mir auch zu heilig. Da will ich die haben und dann sollen aber auch nicht alle jetzt plötzlich Brot machen. Da will ich auch zu sehr dann anders sein. Ja, okay. Gut. Dann bin ich gespannt, was du als nächstes anpackst, welches Projekt. Ich freue mich auch. Schön, dass du eine Puzzle hast. Paddelphase, mal gucken, wie lange es dauert. Ich werde mir auf jeden Fall die Augen wundglotzen an Paddel-Content auf YouTube. Und vielleicht spielen wir mal. Hier in Köln gibt es Plätze, das machen wir mal. Das große Podcaster-Paddelturnier? Ja, vielleicht in der Telegram-Gruppe können wir das vielleicht organisieren.
Es ist auch lustig übrigens, wie schlecht die Telegram-Gruppen gealtert sind, seitdem wir eine haben.
Ist dir das aufgefallen?
Ja, mittlerweile hat jeder Verschwörungstheoretiker eine.
Wir hatten sie noch, als es cool war und die ganzen Informatiker auf Telegram waren.
Heute sagt man, ihr habt eine Telegram-Gruppe, wirklich?
Sollt ihr da mal gucken mit Verfassungsschutz oder so?
Ja, okay.
Okay, schwierig. Aber wir gucken mal, vielleicht können wir, es gibt ja genug Podcasts, die auch zu zweit sind, vielleicht können wir ein größtes große Podcaster-Paddelfight. Podcaster-Paddelturnier. Aber alle haben es noch nie gespielt. Aber gegen Felix Lubrecht und Tobi Schmidt. Ja, vergiss es. Die beiden Sporty Guys. Jeder, lass uns lieber hier gefühlte Fakten machen oder so. Ich glaube, ja. Nee, die sind beide auch sportlich.
Ja gut,
wir finden noch unsere Gegner. Wir finden schon Leute. Aber wir veranstalten, das heißt, wir können die Leute,
wir holen die Leute.
Wir stellen die Regeln auf.
Halte die Augen offen,
mach eine grosse Plakatkampagne, das Podcaster
Paddel pro Turnier, es wird grossartig,
seid dabei. Ansonsten bis nächste Woche und habt eine schöne Zeit.
Nächste Woche habt eine schöne Zeit.
Ja, dich seid dabei. Ansonsten bis nächste Woche und habt eine schöne Zeit. Nächste Woche habt eine schöne Zeit. Wie immer!